on vient de l'entendre vous le devenir
zelensky le président et sonia s'est
également exprimée en ce 9 mai l'ukraine
gagnera la guerre et aucun territoire ne
sera cédé à la russie at il dit ont
rejoint kiev notre envoyé spécial
bastien renouil bonjour bastien est ce
qu'il y a eu des réactions de la
population ukrainienne à cette
démonstration de force du kremlin
aujourd'hui
bonjour et bien assez peu de réactions
en réalité ici les gens n'ont pas
vraiment écouter ce discours de vladimir
poutine auquel ils ont prêté assez
d'attention ce qui les intéresse c'est
bien c'est la réalité de la guerre et
non pas les menaces et la rhétorique
affichée par vladimir poutine depuis le
début du conflit conflit qu'il ne
reconnaît d'ailleurs qu'à moitié
puisqu'ils parlent toujours d'opérations
spéciales même lors de son discours de
ce matin il n'a pas voulu parler de
guerre il n'a pas voulu parler de
l'envahissement de l'ukraine alors les
habitants de calvitie bien ont plutôt
tendance à reprendre une vie normale a
essayé de ne plus faire attention à
toutes ces menaces de vladimir poutine
et essayait bien de jouer et de
continuer à travailler et à vivre
normalement même si les alertes
retentissent plusieurs fois par jour ici
toujours dans la capitale et bien les
habitants de kiev ils font de moins en
moins attention il préfère revenir à la
vie qu'ils connaissaient avant le début
du conflit merci beaucoup bastien pour
ces précisions depuis kiev